[beautiful music playing]
[Flashbacks:] Welcome everybody to my brand new show called.. *clap clap* meme review-
*claP CLAP* First of, we are gonna start off with the sOMEBODY TOUCH MAH SPAGHETT
[tragic music] Pewdiepie kills all the memes the hater says. Excuse me, somebody touch my spaghett..
mEME REVIEW *clap cLAP*
[tragic music] UGANDA KNUCKLES EVERYBODY
Can someone please help this poor knuckles find the wae
They are looking for their queen, they are looking  for their commander..
*clap* next *CLAP* MEEEEEE
Number 15: Burger king foot, the last thing you'd ever wanted in your burger king burger is foot but it'll turn out that is wHaaaAt you gEEet [THE END]
*clap clap* meme review that's right i'm within two days with another meme review
OOOOhho the DisINTEgRatION meme
YEEahhhss of course this is blowing up the same day i posted my last one
and now all the sudden, now all the sudden everyone s- AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
MeEEE- the disintegration meeme it's so funny, it's so funny looking at that shrek
"HEY donkey, I dont feel so good"
this is so sad because shrek has swamp sense which means that he knew he was about to die
that j- *tear*
ooh so sad, this meme is so sad.
so last meme rewiew i rewiewed marvel's Infinity war memes
i didnt bring up the disintegration meme
cause its not that funny, its not that great, its not even chuckle worthy-
it makes me want to die- which it gaves a little bit of point, but neither the less
i see what i must do now. IF I HOLD THE POWERS IN MY HANDS
*CLAP CLAP* someBODY TOUCH MY SPAGHETT
THAT EVERYTIME I CLAP A MEME, A MEME DIES, if that it's not a joke, but truth  itself?
that is not only my duty, but my previliege to rewiew the disintegration meme
because this is garbage, okay.
If you dont want to- if you dont even know where how bad it is, New York Time-
Is that how it is called- Time has rewiew this meme.
WHAaaT?!
Polygon has rewiew this meme, WHAT I AM GONNA DOOO
If you are not familiar with infinity war meme let's give a little bit of context here so you understand
Here is the basic plot summarize
*clap clap* pretty moving, pretty emotional stuff, a lot of characters died in the movie
everyone's favorite supehero and i understand.
this meme immediately gets the seal of containers approvale, you are allowed to cry over this mean
everything is just disintegrating left and right, what meme is going to be destroyed next?
who knows
any meme that goes mainstream will of course get the loss version of it
its okay, we're fine, that was actually pretty good
sorry. ThIS IS SO SAD CAN WE HIT A THOUSAND L-
[Disintegration meme]
HEY- hey who did this?
NOT COOL, DELETE. DELETE THIS RIGHT NOW. DELET-
I'm not laughing. i'M NOT- DELETE THIS MEME
I HATE THIS MEME- STOP WITH THIS STUPID MEME
[more disintegration meme]
i'm shaking. i've never been this mad. Can you stop disintegrating everything?
NOT друг. MY ONLY FRIEND
NOT SPONGEBOB- when will it end?
Oh look its me because i'm crying. anyone that cries just has stood by-
by the way i was not crying, that was fabricated tear, y'all fell for it
scientist say this is the last thing a meme sees before it dies NO-
[meme]
"i dont feel so good, harry" *laughs*
This is funny because when Gandalf dies in Lord of the Rings he disintegrated into little- ff it makes sense.
whenever is see the disintegration meme i wish i was being disintegrating.
"so long, partner"
"i dont feel good"
Oh no canada is disintegrating everybody, what are we going to do, what are we going to do without canadA
ooOOoh no not cAnada ooh canada.
i bet Canada knew it was going to die because Canada has-
*thinking*
Cook sense?
ZACH! i knew it was Zuch behind this, who else has this power
What the hell is this even suppose to mean
I'm not even crying in this. do you think i'm some soy boy? i never cried in my entire life, dont make me laugh pff
"it was the only way, luigi"
Why is it disintegrating the best- the most hurtful way to see someone go?
if they just go *dead sound* it's not as sad as just disappearing and fading into dust
"BUt cAAn yoU DO THIIIiis?" Another dead meme.
This is actually a photorealistic image of what happens when the meme does i fact die that's right
Types of headaches: Migraine, Hypertension, stress, "not feeling so good"
"Meme Review", "memes", hey look at that everybody, someone got into the jokes
"They did it to me" *laughs*
HEY GRANDE. STOP IT. STOP IT. STOP THAT SH*T NOW.
"I could snap my fingers, and bonus meme would cease to exist"
Oh my god. it all makes sense.
"guess i'll die", Thats a pretty good one.
Hey look its my beard disintegrating, that is right i actually didnt have to shave, it was pretty convenient and easy
Please stop the disintegratio- GODDAMNIT
everyone know the original disintegration meme was of course the windows 95s logo
This is an actually old school meme, not a lot of people know about it but now you do know
because here at meme review we care about educating you, make you smarter, make you think
"super intendent i dont feel so good"
This is the steamed hands meme by the way, i havent review this but its probably one of the best meme of all time.
its a comic sketch from the simpson, and... that's it.
"mr. stark i dont feel so gOOooOOd"
that is so funny.
all the memes are just dying, just because im clapping doesnt mean any memes are dying, alright?
this is litteraly just me doing this, meme review, meme review everybody
let all memes die, you know, i dont care, it would be better, can everyone die
can we do that instead- nothing, its not working, its not working. STOP IT
This meme gets zzZZwah-eh mm *clap clap* meme review
I know what you are thinking. do we have time for bonus meme felix. this is a garbage episode with a garbage meme
honestly you really just melt this didnt you
excuse me, nno, no thats not true, at all
what do yu think i'm some greedy greedy bastard?
*BRAD?!*
[Brad snap his fingers, bonus meme disappears ]
leave a like if you like like things
and if you dont please go ahead and subscribe to this channel right now.
cause i dont like anything either.
i think we will have a really great time you and i together lets go on an adventure, together.
this has been pewdiwpie, goodbye everybody.
OH and also dont forget to check out the merch
represent.com/pewdiepie, only two days leeft
*clap clap* until next time meme review
[disappears]